el autor de la matanza es un joven de 19
años que había estudiado en esa misma
escuela el arma estaba registrada a su
nombre parece que obtuvo el permiso hace
menos de dos semanas y estaba
desequilibrado el presidente ruso
vladimir putin ha ordenado que se
establezcan criterios más estrictos de
cara a la obtención del permiso de armas
en uso en el hospital clínico infantil
de tataristán están ingresados 18 niños
6 de ellos están en estado crítico a
estas horas se saben algunas cosas sobre
el asesino que ese grado allí mismo en
esa escuela hace cuatro años y entró
después en la universidad donde estudió
como especialista en informática sus
profesores los recuerdan como un chico
callado y respetuoso unos días antes de
la matanza el atacante puso en marcha un
canal en telegram que bautizó como dios
donde se autodenominaba como un ser
superior por la mañana se fotografió a
sí mismo con una máscara donde se veía
la palabra a dios afirmando que iba a la
escuela a cometer una matanza y que
después se iba a suicidar claro que al
final ha acabado entregándose a la
policía